[Musique]
Irne Chagot propose voyage sans
passeport
[Musique]
au cours des nombreux siècles dans le
monde entier le bois était la base de
toute construction humaine le fer fut
connu et utilisé en Afrique en même
temps que dans toutes les autres parties
du monde mais la technique de la fonte
resta un secret professionnel clos connu
seulement d'un seul clan dans chaque
tribu maintenant le fer est bon marché
et il est produit en abondance mais le
rit ancien reste bien qu'il commence un
peu à
décliner de tous les arbres des forêts
pas plus de deux sortes seulement
fournissait un charbon de bois qui
brûlait avec une chaleur suffisamment
intense pour servir le
fondeur et le fondeur estafricain le
connaissait et garder ce
secret il avait besoin de tuyaux pour
ses soufflets qui résisteraient à la
chaleur et il découvrit que la glaise
d'une certaine sorte pouvait être jetée
dans les flammes sans craquer ça c'était
aussi un autre
secret après trois ou quatre semaines de
travail sa préparation fut complète
alors il creusa un trou pour recevoir le
métal fondu éprouva ses soufflets
construisit son fourneau avec des
plaques de glaise étala une base de
charbon de bois mis en position les
tuyaux d'argile pour les soufflets et
étala le mineret de fer dans les espaces
entre eux les soufflets étaient
fabriqués prêts à
[Musique]
souffler
et peu à peu une substance tenant lieu
de fonte apparut au sommet du Monceau de
glaise Dawa ce qui veut dire
magique alors le rit des fondeur était
[Musique]
commencé
le travail est
[Musique]
accompli une lourde masse noire est
alors tirée du puit pour
inspection
produire cette quantité de fer était
l'affaire de nombreuses
semaines et il restait pour le forgeron
à battre cette
matière et à en tirer
[Musique]
parti
les Africains de l'Est ont un grand sens
pratique et ils s'intéressent peu très
peu aux Arts Décoratifs excepté pour
l'ornement
personnel les jeunes filles prennent
beaucoup de temps et font grand embarras
au sujet de leurs
oreilles
[Musique]
elles peuvent allonger leur lob d'oreill
bien au-dessus des limites que la nature
leur a
troyé l'ajustage des bracelets est un
travail de spécialiste une fois en
position ils sont là pour la vie la
richesse et la position sociale d'une
femme peut être mesurée par la quantité
et la qualité de ses bijoux d'ailleurs
il est vrai qu'il en est de même quant à
l'homme turcana nomade bien sûr il part
sa tête avec de la glaise cette glaise
est coloré modelé et apprêté pour
recevoir des plumes d'autruche de
cérémonie la parure de tête et laaboré
restera en place pendant 2 mois avant
d'être
renouvelé une tribu les W Kamba a
découvert que c'était un profit que de
contenter les touristes il s'y
appliquent
[Musique]
à l'université de maerer une tradition
est ressusciter ce qui sommeille depuis
des vingtaines de
siècles
une forme de l'art là-bas n'a jamais
sommeillé c'est le culte de la musique
et de la
danse les Africains de l'Est battent
partout leur rythme complexe sur leurs
étranges instruments à son de leur
propre
invention tel que cette harp en forme
d'arc de la contrée de
sucuma voici une lire à H
cordes
des trompettes à de
notes
[Musique]
et la trompette a une note
forceère
[Musique]
[Rires]
et la cornemuse de giriama dans l'outre
est constitué vous allez le voir par les
vastes Bajou du joueur
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
uma
ce sont de très longs corps qui
accompagnent ces groupes de
[Musique]
danseursy
accélérer avec le battement des
tambours
[Musique]
IR ch vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de Caltex et le Solange
pter son anque V lu Perini montage
Pierre Michel illustration sonore deise
Glazer
[Musique]